at smith's bar and restaurant tom young
is looking to keep his spirits up as he
navigates yet another obstacle
disappointment shock disbelief i mean
we've been looking forward to the cruise
ships coming for so long the caribbean
princess was the first cruise ship
scheduled to arrive in bc after two
years
docking in victoria on wednesday and
vancouver on thursday but the route
abruptly canceled we're disappointed
that the first ship won't be coming
frankly changes to itineraries do happen
especially at the start or the end of
the season those are not uncommon
princess cruz says the sailing would not
continue because of maintenance but
passenger aly carroll believes that is
not the only thing saying there is lots
of covid the whole 12th floor is an
isolation ward the ship now at level
orange means the center for disease
control is investigating we don't know
what the real answer is but obviously
disappointing for those in vancouver and
victoria
there's over 350
going into victoria and stops in
victoria and there's over 300 ships
coming to and departing from vancouver
but for gastown businesses struggling
it's a loss of thousands of potential
customers a lot of people come off those
cruise ships and just trickle down it's
like a new city coming onto onto into
another city it's a shock to the staff
as well because now we're any any
staffing we do for her so it's like okay
well now we're going to cut you they
won't be back up to the almost three
billion dollars
of value that cruz brings to canada this
year but we're hoping maybe by 2023 2024
we'll start to see that grow despite the
slow restart belonging believes it will
be a healthy cruising season he like
others taking a glassful approach the
next ship to arrive in vancouver is
sunday bringing all the staff and
hopefully points will be flown and the
place will be good for them krista dao
global news